soir jacky
bonsoir qu'est ce que vous me conseillez
ce soir jacky le péché c'est pas nouveau
je connais monsieur c'est lova moor
c'est bien ce que je disais c'est pas
nouveau c'est peut-être pas nouveau
monsieur mais c'est éternel
[Musique]
bonsoir on n'est pas double jeu mais je
vais quand même te demander ton prénom
c'est comment son mari
ouais on est disons que honda jourdain
ouï qu un séjour bon ton père faisait
des jo va moore sans le savoir
c'est ça alors tu es une petite fille en
fait ce qu'on sait pas très bien si
c'est politique de la compagnie au
départ n'ont pas tout à fait tu vois je
suis une paysanne savoureux imagine bien
dans les champs en fin de circuit très
demandeur
bean et des haricots lingots d'or 1
minute 10 mois alors quand j'étais petit
tu aller en vacances à l'île d'oléron
chez la grand-mère de ta cousine de se
passer commande là bas
eh bien ça se passe et c'était des
vacances merveilleux charmante ça a été
les premières fuites
la nuit je me sauvais je faisais du stop
schaller discours bah ouais c'est ça a
été les premiers amours c'est vrai que
tu te c'est vrai que tu te couches est
huit heures du soir que tu dormais
jusqu'à minuit et que tu ressortait à
minuit et sa grand mère se trouvait très
reposée finalement pas ce qu'est ce
qu'elles sont sages quand elle pensait
que je dormais toujours quoi là on
faisait les diablesses la nuit alors les
amours de vacances alors les amours de
vacances je crois que j'ai dû échanger
mon premier baiser sur une des plages et
je ne savais pas que d'ouvrir la bouche
battre la lande évoque la langue mais
alors je me sens utile mais qu'est-ce
qui fait c'est bien ouais j'ai trouvé ça
c'est dégueulasse alors j'ai raconté sa
mère j'ai des coups tient garçons kevin
car ça motive c'est normal la petite
fille à faire tu t'y l'habitude et puis
une fois je me suis très bien et vite et
ça va maintenant
ouais ça va est ok tu sais j'ai une
bouche qui appelle les ege c'est béthune
trompé par est initié par dix mois alors
bon sens et de baisers premier baiser
profond mais pour le reste c'était
arrivé à quel âge avait pas alors pour
le reste tu sais la campagne on est très
précoce balayage l'attend au pire alors
moi déjà j'allais me planquer dans l'est
dans les champs pour regarder les plus
grandes à faire leurs premiers et
valeureux et puis moi j'ai dû avoir
versé pas vers 12 ans je crois quand
même mais quand même après je suis resté
de 12 ans à 20 ans et ça j'ai recommencé
à 20 ans ah bon non ce n'est pas plus
que ses 8 ans on est touché par un non
combat le mec c'était très mal démerder
enfin je crois un petit aperçu que
c'était joli à quel âge à la très tôt
parce que mes parents me faisait monter
sur la table de la cuisine
alors ce que j'avais pris mon bas et on
faisait danser et j'entendais on disait
qu est ce qu est la jolie course cette
petite fille nue niche vers quel âge ça
je devais avoir 6 6 ans ouais sept ans
alors il y avait des escaliers je me
souviens chez moi et j'étais déjà
exhibitionniste je descendais ni les
escaliers et j'attendais que mon père et
ma mère
enfin ce genre de réflexion ça me pose
énormément et cdh a pris assez tôt tout
cela très tôt très tôt
alors pendant que j'étais en vacances
alors les ronds et vd fois tes parents
venaient et à ce moment là vous aviez
sur la place du village parce que l'epo
quand on regardait pas la télé j'étais
en vacances chez les gens on voit on se
réunissait sur la place du village il y
avait tous les vieux du village qui
était là et puis bon il racontait des
histoires incroyables
puis on était là ricaner bêtement qu'on
allait leur voler des bouteilles de
pineau parce que ces finales du nom des
gens et nos parents et puis on se veut
un petit coup et puis voilà c'était
sympa c'était moi alors tu es monté à
paris très jeune finalement donc pas
disons j'avais fait mes études pour et
éducatrices de
de cas sociaux et je devais faire après
cette école oui bah oui j'étais une
petite des voeux et tous ses
petits-enfants
et puis je suis monté à paris faire un
stage dans une école et au lieu d'aller
à l'école je passais mes nuits dans les
boîtes qu'un jour j'ai rencontré un
chorégraphe qui travaille au crazy horse
ou ailleurs et il m'a dit écoute et têtu
est très doué pour la dent j'ai donné
des cours gratuits si le vent ne gagnez
pas tellement d'argent et pauvres et un
soir il en mai voir le spectacle du
crazy et puis j'étais assez fasciné il
m'a dit de prendre ce but encaissé à peu
près à la bolivie si tu ne seras pas
alors voilà je serai pas polluer nos
systèmes pour le web mais j'étais très
jeune quand même des états y existait
déjà il existait depuis très longtemps -
t'es pris en vacances c'était à saint
tropez à gaz est fasciné par le milliard
$ donc c'est quelque chose de commun
avec bardot c'est qu'en fait et comme ça
tu es sculpturale en fait au fond d'une
femme très simple le taf un gentil nous
et moi je suis là la bonne terrienne
voilà j'ai la tête sur les épaules
j'ai sur terre
et oui je suis simple et elle est là
hélas est bien sûr cette grande qualité
un an quand tu fais fasciné par bach l1
jeudi parce que vraiment je trouve
sublime et ce qu'elle fait en ce moment
pour les animaux bon je trouve ça
merveilleux
tu fais quoi toi pour les aliments
importés trois chats écoute mes trois
chats je les aime déjà c'est déjà
beaucoup
et puis tous les tous les chats que que
je trouve je les amène chez moi et je
les nourris je les lave je les brosse et
ben touati fait beaucoup de choses pour
les cochons qui sommeille au fond de
chaque offre aussi les coudes quand tu
fais quoi maintenant je fais rien je
vais je me repose je prends le soleil
jeune âge je m'éclate de temps en temps
avec le rosé ça je dois le dire
j'adore manger j'adore manger j'adore
manger et puis j'attends lance tu fais
des siestes l'été ouais miraculeuse ou
normales crapuleuses c'est quoi qu'est
ce que tu fais pendant les siestes
crapuleuses qui baisent le petit buzz
ah oui ça m'est arrivé non généralement
général j'adore j'adore dormir donc je
peux viser en rêvant si tu fais tu fais
la sieste ou chamakh oui oui c'est bien
si tu verras que j'adore parce que ça te
ça te met dans un dans un demi sommeil
parce que tu sais que si tu bouges trop
le hamac eux
mais voilà alors chef d'or je peux pas
dormir complète nous voilà j'adore comme
ça toi et comme sur un nuage de monter
un grand fantasme
we dance et sieste comme ça de me
réveiller c'est que tu rêves de faire du
cheval nu oui ç'a toujours été un rêve
pourquoi mais j'ai peur des chevaux de
voir ce que je sais pas je trouve qu'un
cheval c'est bon de toute façon c'est
beau et puis je trouve que la
morphologie de la femme parfaitement
toutefois la l'arrière train de la femme
et la mère près du cheval quoi de plus
beau c'est vrai en plus avec de crinière
qui flottent au vent
bon voilà ça va très bien images par
messieurs et 10 mois pour être là jamais
fait quand même peur des chevaux ah bon
alors je préfère se boucher les armes
je vais énormément c'est bernard d'un
kit a initié la victime qu'est ce qui
t'a fait dire au début comme j'étais pas
très doué en histoire de france alors il
m'a acheté toute la collection des
délits breton assez bien alors sont mes
livres de chevet tutu tricote ouais ça
je le crois pas à toi alors là tout ce
que tu me racontes et jusque là c'est
sexiste d'un seul coup de s'imaginer en
train de tricoter des achats j'aime
écouter
mais un grand tablier le grand mère je
prends mes deux grandes aiguilles mais
je sais pas tricoter je tricote des
écharpes de trois mètres de haut
est ce que ton jeu il est obligé
d'apporter d'échapper au sénat je ne
force pas la portée par exemple dix mois
il ya une question qui me turlupine
c'est quelle expression bernardin way
quantité est bon il y avait plein de
filles au case ih oui pourquoi il a
choisi toi il faudra peut-être lui poser
la question quand on arrive c'est dur en
parler quand même tous les deux ouais
parce que il mais il m'a dit que j'avais
un côté un côté enfant un côté pur
malgré les apparences de diablesse été
fidèles bernard da te fais dire j'ai pas
espérer pompiers tentent de lancer un
oui progresser ou alors mais j'ai fait
était fidèle avec mon corps n'est pas
traitée dans ma tête j'ai pas d'elle
c'est mieux que l'inversé l'industrie
d'internet et pas avec ton corps aussi
beaucoup qui n'a pas été fidèle il parle
c'est pas tellement tour est jolie fille
d une sacrée contre le vent ce crazy
horse et la concurrence il ya 24 superbe
beauté qui sont renouvelés tous les
trois ans elles sont toujours jeune et
belle donc ouais mais bon tu vois je
suis toujours là toujours présent et ma
peine et sa reine alors la différence
d'âge entre vous c'est génial j'aime pas
les jeunes hommes jeunes j'aime les
hommes qui m'apporte intellectuellement
pour moi c'est beaucoup plus important
que
on les jeunes c'est facile tu peux tu
pleures comptable à la plagne axa axa et
à partir de quel âge avait sa chance est
là à 30 ans ça va alors j avais mal
vaille et traditions anton pays en
chante maritime les femmes pour gardez
le encore une peau ferme et fraîche se
roule nu dans la rosée du 1er mai oui
tout à fait je vous appelle ça doit
regardes tu vois ça marche et ça marché
paraît que bon c'est une vieille coutume
charentaises et va il paraît que ça
raffermit la peau et en y réfléchissant
je me dis que finalement c'est peut-être
le le froid qui
ça a bien marché semble important c est
qu est le secret du tessin alors le
secret de ce qu'ils ont été refaits
d'abord non pas du tout jamais été
refait non non mais bon ça dépend les
époques dans ma vie j'en ai plus ou
moins parce que c'est une femme
lorsqu'elle prend la pilule sa double de
volume est salée alors qu'est ce que je
fais pour mes dupond la baie de messages
en effet caresser c'est pour ça qu'il
reste dur et beau il faut il faut les
aimer c'est comme ça encore et puis je
prends je les douches a menacé tous deux
sur toulouse seul à l'epo ils sont en
forme de pomme en forme de poire on
penche pas en forme de pomme est là on
voit pas bien parce que les cheveux ah
oui c'est plutôt pop le crayon ne
soutient pas non mais pas de molesme je
n'aime pas le test n'est pas encore ça
viendra de temps et il est et on les
voit pas ils sont comment enlever son
petit accent de son petit puis
heureusement parce que je trouve ça
indécent ne fait pas les gros tétons non
je trouve ça indécent mais peut-être que
pour un homme ses terres au petit grain
cet automne
mais pourquoi est ce que tu es sensible
et et on voit très sensible même si son
petit train to confront quels conseils
tu donnerais aux femmes pour garder de
beauce un soutien-gorge travail et les
millions et ma foi un saint qui tombe
ses palais comment ça peut être érotique
les zones qui adore les sentiments dans
un décolleté maintenant avec les scellés
en voiture aux armatures ça remonte tout
mais tu peux pas supporter nos pilotes
n'ont jamais jamais c'est bien être
libre voilà ce que je suis au bout mais
j'imagine oui j'aime me balader nu
j'adore sortir le vin son côté le soleil
a voulu former bien méchante habits
comment montrer à non non je peux
toucher voir la fermeté
ah ouais et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de linda hardy tube abonnez vous
je m'étais un peu ce bleu